The order is the mascot of hell
So, first of all, from us in the a team, it's fine to say that this is an animal with three heads, right?
But let's turn it into the wolf we thought about a long time ago and throw it at Mr. Higuchi
right
away.
It looks like
it's getting tangled up, so if you put "no"
around here and make your head fake, you could have done too much talking from your head
.
I stroked the head of each of them and jumped into the whirlpool of lust
Let's respect that I
've fixed
it I can walk straight
Let's raise a cool low half
yeah
Dave
so much
rar  It's a creature that's hard to feel, so I'll eat it to the limit.In exchange,
I'm strong in fasting
.
Hobbies
: Listening to music is good, even if
you can't play musical instruments.